hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
Apple was no stranger to lawsuits but
the last few weeks have been rough for
the company that's because the United
States Supreme Court has ruled for a
customer antitrust lawsuit to go ahead
against Apple so what has Apple done
this time and why I can see this suing
them in this video we'll find out
[Music]
antitrust laws are in place to regulate
how businesses deal with each other and
their customers the reason for antitrust
laws is to promote fair competition this
is mainly to stop monopolies from
forming or companies taking too much of
the market and abusing their power the
issue is that some people arguing
against Apple citing that they've
effectively created a monopoly in their
App Store an Apple devices such as
iPhones if you want to download an app
the only way to currently do so is
through the Apple App Store here the
developers of the apps pay a yearly
listing fee and give Apple a 30%
Commission on the sale of their app so
since you can't buy an app without the
App Store it's claimed that Apple is
abusing its power to make you pay 30%
more for apps than you otherwise would
if the developers are allowed to sell to
you directly Apple has been facing the
same class-action lawsuit from customers
for over eight years the company's main
defense is that they are simply the
middleman between the developers and
consumers Apple argued that if consumers
had issues with prices they should go
after the developers who set the prices
however in a five to four vote in the
Supreme Court where Brett Cavanaugh was
the deciding vote the court voted to
allow the lawsuit to go ahead Cavanaugh
stated that quote plaintiffs purchased
apps directly from Apple and therefore
are direct purchasers unquote in short
this means the consumers were free to go
after Apple the trial and the verdict is
still a while away and legal experts
believe it may take three years to
resolve but it's not a good sign for
Apple when the highest court in the
United States decided to go through with
the lawsuit perhaps to an extent Apple's
share price fell on that news
so all of this aside what does it mean
if Apple loses this case potentially it
could mean that Apple may have to offer
partial refunds on all iPhone apps since
the iPhone was introduced in 2007
needless to say this would put a huge
dent in Apple's cash pile Apple has paid
app developers thirty four billion
dollars in 2018 alone so what numbers of
that large refunding 30% of those
hosting costs over the past ten plus
years would be pretty devastating for
the company Apple may also be forced to
allow alternative methods for buying
apps ones where they don't take a cut
this would theoretically make apps
cheaper and more accessible to consumers
if Apple loses then it could set a
precedent for other tech platforms to be
similarly sued and this could have a
knock-on effect across the whole tech
sector for example Microsoft recently
announced a diskless Xbox meaning if
games are only available through their
store then Microsoft may also be accused
of running a monopoly the case even has
risky implications for Amazon and Google
but even if Apple wins the Supreme Court
has removed a massive hurdle in filing
antitrust lawsuits against platforms
this means that there could be more
suits in the future regardless of the
outcome of this case the landscape of
tech may be altered by this lawsuit on
the other side there have been many
voices and politics and in the public
calling for the breakup of large tech
companies in a short space of time a
handful of companies have gained so much
momentum that they are not only worth
billions but also holds so much control
over their markets to a point where this
has never been seen before so on the one
hand potentially this case may make it
easier to break up big tech monopolies
but on the other hand there might be
some unintended consequences it seems to
me that this is really an assault on our
free enterprise system because it's
no-fault monopolies under her proposal
if you reach twenty five billion dollars
in revenues you've got to split up it's
a drastic measure that doesn't comport
with where our antitrust laws are today
could harm innovation and honestly could
end up harming consumers in the long run
so this case is far from over it's
really just begun but the Supreme Court
stance has been noted there will be an
interesting minefield that tech
companies will have to navigate in the
coming years
they have to fight their competitors
while at the same time maintain public
trust and that's a difficult line to
walk politicians and growing public
distrust will undoubtably make this job
more difficult so what do you think does
Apple have a monopoly on the app market
and what do you think about the general
idea of suing companies for getting too
big let me know your thoughts in the
comments section below so an update to
this video as it was being made some
news has broken there could be a
potential antitrust investigation by the
Justice Department and the Federal Trade
Commission against Google Facebook and
Amazon Google is claimed to have a
monopoly in their Play Store and Google
search Amazon may have investigations
into their low prices and Facebook may
have to let go of Instagram and whatsapp
and also have the influence curtailed
needless to say this is going to be a
wild ride
[Music]
so thanks for watching this video this
has been to gogo and you've been
watching cold fusion if you're
interested in topics like this and much
more you should definitely consider
subscribing alright so I'll catch you
again soon for the next video
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]